anyway the fact is uh in 1997 there was
a a press conference on the White House
lawn and Bill Clinton was there and you
can actually see it in the movie contact
uh with uh past guest on my show at
least andrewian who would make a great
guess for you the wife the Widow of the
late great Carl Sagan and she co-wrote
the book contact in which the movie is
based and in that they take a scene from
this uh so that was 1997 1998. they took
a scene from The Late 90 late 1996 when
there was a declared announcement
um from a discovery of meteorite relics
in Antarctica of possible respiratory
microbial respiratory byproducts or
something like that
slow
good afternoon
I'm glad to be joined by my
Science and Technology advisor Dr Jack
Gibbons
to make a few comments about today's
Announcement by NASA
more than four billion years ago
this piece of rock was formed as a part
of the original crust of Mars
after billions of years
it broke from the surface and began a 16
million year journey through space that
would end here on Earth
it arrived in a meteor shower 13
000 years ago
and in 1984 an American scientist on an
annual U.S government mission to search
for meteors on Antarctica picked it up
and took it to be studied
appropriately it was the first rock to
be picked up that year
Rock number 84.001
today
Rock 84001
speaks to us across all those billions
of years and millions of miles
it speaks of the possibility of life
if this discovery is confirmed it will
surely be one of the most stunning
insights into our universe that science
has ever uncovered now that was actually
you know vetted by NASA and had to be to
be broadcast from the White House lawn
it was actually some articles are
published in in science and so forth
peer-reviewed and everything and that
showed that their meteorite activity
that can come from Mars and land on the
earth at one thing and then that life
could persist potentially and by the way
that's never been retracted formally and
it's never been like there's been a rich
oh that we were wrong it's just
ambiguous it hasn't been confirmed or
refuted that's pretty wrong it's pretty
Wrong by the way
the fact occurs to me that
um given that there is life on Earth and
given that it arose a few hundred
million years after the origin of the
earth we've had four billion years for
these little chunks of rocks which by
the way you can win if you're one of the
next 100 uh subscribers to my mailing
list Brian keating.com I send out
meteorites to people in America all I
can afford is to send out American
meteorites uh through the U.S Postal
Service but gravity will deliver it uh
once you get it
um given that we haven't found life on
mars or on uh any other evidence of Life
on MAR is there some amount of um of
Bayesian prior reasoning that we can
then diminish the probability of life
being present throughout the Universe in
other words we often hear that as soon
as life came on Earth which you know we
don't know how that came about maybe
it's panspermia uh maybe it's not but
kind of the fact that reverse panspermia
can occur we can kick tardigrades off of
a chunk of the Grand Canyon and can go
into space
how come uh can we use that to reason
that life is actually not that abundant
as many people think and certainly not
Advanced technological life or am I you
know is this not an appropriate way to
view the problem well I don't think we
can go quite that far but the fact that
we do not see abundant very obvious Life
on Mars or other bodies in the solar
system all else being equal lowers our
probability of life being ubiquitous in
the universe on the other hand if your
theory that you're trying to update is
one percent of earth-sized planets have
life on them then the existence of No
Life on Mars doesn't change your prior
probability very much at all and one
percent of the planets out there would
still be billions of uh places to have
life out there in the universe so uh you
know I I draw a big distinction between
life and anything that you think of as
advanced intelligent life right that's a
very very different question I think
that there are good Bayesian reasons to
think that there are not that many
Advanced civilizations in our galaxy
that is something that we could have
observed very very easily and we haven't
yeah and every time I say that the the
UFO people come on and say ah wait until
this guy is is shown up and six months
when the new report is released but this
has been going on for 10 years and the
new report has never really shown me up
so I'm pretty confident about that but
that's very different than saying is
there simple unicellular life out there
that could be everywhere that could be
on Europa that could be even there could
be even multicellular life on Europe but
we don't know
um in the oceans of Europa but we'll
have to go look you know the best
Bayesian is not get very far we only
have two or three data points so we need
to collect a lot more data and the
exciting thing is we're gonna do it
that's kind of awesome we're going to be
updating our priors in a substantial way
yeah yeah and I think if nothing else
that Discovery in the late 1996
demonstrates that you know people think
oh it would change Humanity Forever at
the discovery even of a microde of slime
mold on Proxima Centauri B would change
forever we'd have this community see no
it wouldn't be and there's proof that I
would because no one like 99 of the
people that even heard about this in
1996 probably still think it was
accurate or could be be true and I don't
think we've had this you know great
Kumbaya moment across Humanity
[Music]
[Music]